et
[Musique]
pour reconquérir la terre les shadoks
veulent faire comme les jbe charme et
gêne avec de la musique
les shadoks note musiciens vont passer à
l'attaqué
[Musique]
mais toutes ces expéditions shadoks
décidément tomber mais celle-là arrivait
comme par hasard à l'heure du thé au
moment justement où les jib il venait
chez gégène lui jouer sa musique
préférée
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et c'était un spectacle absolument
charmant de voir ces petites bêtes de
faire des sérénades arjen est avec lui
dans ses le menu
c'est juste à ce moment là que les
premiers ont bu longue portée de la vie
musicale j'adore éclatèrent ces [ __ ]
de cirque un tour un seul mais un gant
si gros qu'on croyait presque qu'il
allait éclater les jib y avait dû le
retenir et il lui dire écoute gégène les
shadoks ça vaut pas la peine de se
mettre dans des états pareils ça serait
beaucoup plus amusant de les laisser
venir et de leur jouer des tours avant
de les manger définitivement tous de les
mettre au garde manger
or les jib y avait un plan un plomb à
base de petites boîtes
les petites boîtes jbe comme leurs noms
l'indiquent était tout simplement des
petites boîtes des petites boîtes
cosmique qui pouvait transformer
n'importe quoi ont pratiquement
n'importe quoi et laisser pantois
c'était très utile pour les voyages
interstellaires par exemple quand on
tournait dans un endroit où il n'y avait
que de la lumière on mettait le côté
lumière vers la lumière et les autres
côté fournissait choix du show soit de
l'électricité soit des rayonnements
atomique soit de la musique du 6e compte
et on pouvait faire sortie ou entrer
tout ce qui n'était pas prévu comme les
autres côtés y compris rien du tout et
les voilà partis dans la campagne avec
gêne et leur petit bois mais quelles
étaient leurs plans
[Musique]